roasted squash hummus
start with my take on razal hanud a
classic Moroccan spice blend in a dry
pan toast Cinnamon cloves coriander
fenugreek and fennel seeds then add
mustard seeds and cumin when the seeds
start to pop they're ready
at paprika and grind into a fine powder
for the hummus peel and chop butternut
squash put on a baking tray and add
garlic simply bashed and chopped Ginger
drizzle with olive oil season and
sprinkle over the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour until soft
allowed to cool and place in a blender
tahini cooked chickpeas a dash of lemon
juice
and a drizzle of olive oil
flits into a luxuriously creamy and
textures roasted squash hummus